Hello, everyone. This is
Pediatric Neurology 2.
And I am once again,
Dr. Thomas Chan,
my email, making
sure my highlighter
is working. And
let's get started.
All right, the
session objectives,
really going to
talk about one major
finding, neurologic
finding we see in
kids, and that's
hypotonia. A lot of
conditions that can
cause hypotonia,
going to give you the
most important ones,
I believe, talk
about head shapes,
different head shapes,
infection in kids
that can cause
neurological issues, and
of course, trauma.
Unfortunately, these
things happen, and we
need to discuss it.
All right, so the
neurological findings,
you're going to do
an exam on infants,
which you learned
about, and you can
see different issues,
right? Hopefully,
they have usually
normal So most kids,
most infants that you
see, they should not
be lying flat on the
table like they're lying
on a beach, right? So
it should not be just
hands and feet splayed
out, right? If you
see an infant like
that, that's probably
hypotonic. When they
come out, when they were
in the womb, they were
in a flexed position
in the womb. And when
they come out, they
should be like that,
right? So remember my
trusty baby, so you see
the legs are a little
bent, the arms are a
little bit flexed as
well, so they should
not be like completely
flat, right? So that
is very, very normal.
All right, so
they can have
fasciculations like
twitching, be very
tight, rigidity,
even *******.
They can be
asymmetrically, you
know, maybe
one side of the
body is stronger
than another,
right? The right
arm, right leg, and
the left is good and
the left side not
so good. Or maybe
the grip on one
side is stronger than
another, right? So
you're looking
for asymmetry in
general. And sometimes
the muscular tone,
right? There's such a
thing as hemihypertrophy
in infants where
one side of the
body is bigger or
stronger than another,
right? So, and
epicitonis, which is
a severe finding. That
doesn't look normal
when they're severely
hyperextended.
All right, so all
infants, we do these
maneuvers to make sure
they're not hypotonic,
right? That their tone
is good. So the one
thing you also always
want to do, most babies
are on their back. And
so when you lift them
up, what do they do
when they lift up,
right? Are they like a
rag doll where the head
is lagging back?
Remember, the head is kind
of bigger than most of
the body when they're
young and the body
kind of catches up.
So it's like they're
lagging back and they
have not much tone.
That's not a great sign.
Or also, we always put
them on their stomach
and see what they
do. right so you'll
put them on the back
and you can pick them
up and so they can
can they fight you a
little bit and show some
strength um put them
on their belly and do
they fall over like
a little wet noodle
you know and that's not
normal either right
so they should have
some tone they should
have some tone uh and
as they get older and
older they can kind
of hold themselves
midline you can sometimes
see them struggling,
pushing themselves
off the table, lifting
the head up. So
these are all good
signs. Again, it depends
on how old the infant
is, but you're going
to do these tests.
And the last one is
something that you
actually have to do, which
is you have to actually
pick up the infant
in your hands and see
what they do, right?
They shouldn't slip
through your hands.
They should be holding
themselves like
a gymnast on the
ring, right? So they
should hold themselves
up very easily
like this and that's
a sign of good
tongue. If they fall
through your hands
that's a bad sign. Of
course you never want
to drop the baby.
Usually sometimes they're
slipping through your
hands and you have to
feel like you're grabbing
them. If you ever
feel like you have to
grab the infant then
that's a sign of a
low tongue. These are
all the a lot of the
conditions that can cause
hypotonia. We'll talk
about some of them.
We're not going to
talk about all of them.
All right. So one of
the important ones
to know is cerebral
palsy. All right. I
believe you got some
of this in previous
lecture. The biggest
takeaways, it's a huge
topic. You can talk
two hours on just CP.
But the most
important takeaway is
it's a non
-progressive insult to
the neurological
system, all right?
Whatever happened,
happened, and it's
not progressing
anymore. So
it's not like a
metabolic condition
and, you know,
things are accumulating
and worsening
over time. It's
just, if it's like,
so one side of the
body is not working
right, like the
left side, it's
just going to be like
that. And it's not
going to spread
to the right side.
so could be birth
history you know problems
********* baby a
hypoxic event and
that's usually what
happened there was some
kind of insult
somewhere along the way
that's causing this
that caused the cerebral
palsy right the *******
type is the most
common type even
though there are many
many different types
and that's where you
see upper motor
neuron lesion findings
increased deep tendon
reflexes, spasticity,
clonus, and like a
positive Bavinsky, right?
Positive Bavinsky's can
be normal in infants,
but they usually go
away over time. In
this case, you know,
you might see a two
-year-old and you do
Bavinsky or older, and
they still have it
positive where it should
have gone away, right?
And what's clonus, a
lot of students
don't know this. even
residents don't really
know how what clonus is
or feels like basically
it's it's severely
hyper reflexic right
so when you do reflexes
they should uh kick
up right or you know
react right clonus is
like react and then
they kind of beat even
more afterwards so it
could be a severe
reaction and a few beats
after all right um so
so that's clonus one
or two beats sometimes
can be okay but if
it's like feet that's
a lot all right um
in infants what we
usually do to check is is
actually dorsiflex
the feet right you
dorsiflex feet really
quickly and usually get
one or two beats like
and that's normal right
so a child you suspect
might have cerebral
palsy You dorsiflex
quickly and you go,
all right, so that's
clonus, sustained clonus.
All right, first
condition we're
talking about, spinal
muscular atrophy.
And this is a classic,
what we call floppy
baby, right? So when
you hear floppy baby,
also known as really
very, very
hypotonic baby,
like no tone, and this
is the baby that's
just kind of lying
there like on the beach.
It cannot fight
gravity at all, right?
Most common type that
you see is the type
1, what we call Warding
-Hoffman disease,
right? Severely
hypotonic, very little
muscle mass, doesn't
come as a surprise.
And it's a problem
with the anterior horn.
So I think you got this
from another lecture
as well. Do you have
absent deep tendon
reflexes? And because
they have no musculature,
and for super hypotonic,
you know, they have
problems swallowing,
so they can't eat
right. They've even
had problems breathing.
Very classically, they
have tongue
fasciculations,
right? They end up
in wheelchairs very,
very early in their
life and physically
handicapped. And
I say physically
because a lot of times
these kids, the brain
is working fine,
right? So the classic
infant is just laying
there, can't do
much, but it has
very, very bright eyes
and looking at you,
right? Will smile.
You can see that
observing everything.
And, you know, these
are the type of kids
that I've encountered
that have had spinal
muscular atrophy. They
just bodies are just
not working right. They're
in their wheelchairs,
but they can have
a conversation with
you. They understand
a lot. And it's quite
tragic because it's like
the brain is working
fine and the body just
doesn't, right? Down
syndrome, another
syndrome, and every
system you're going to
get, Down syndrome is
going to be in it
because it has so many
findings, right? So
there's the common physical
findings that a lot of
us will associate it
with Down syndrome.
I list them here, but
one physical finding
neurologically, it's
not something you actually
see, it's what you
feel, right? So this
is when, this is the
infant that you pick
up, and they kind of
start falling through
your hands a little bit,
or when you do a little
bit, pull them up
when they're, when
they're supine, the head's
lagging a little
bit, right? So they
have, you know, generalized
hypotonia. They're
not floppy baby like
Ruddick-Hoffman, which
is severely hypotonic,
but they're just a
little, they're definitely
weaker than they
should be, right? So
So that's one of those
physical findings that
it's not something
you see. It's something
you kind of feel as
you're doing the exam,
all right? And, of
course, they have lots
of associated problems.
Basically, every
system you're going to
see Down syndrome is
there that they have a
problem, all right?
And this is something a
lot of people don't
realize. They're very,
very flexible a lot
of times. You can see
this infant able to put
his foot in his mouth,
which a lot of infants
do. but you see a
lot of them have
significant joint laxity.
All right, Prader
-Willi syndrome,
another very
interesting syndrome.
This is the problem
with the deletion of
paternal chromosome
15, right? Always a
board question, it's
all over the place.
And the biggest thing is
that when they're
first born,
they're very, very
hypotonic and weak.
They don't actually
eat well. But one day
they, it's like
something, a switch goes
off in the brain,
they get older, like
a young child, and
all of a sudden they
start eating, and they
never stop eating,
right? And they
never want to stop
eating, they never
feel full, and it
leads to severe
obesity, right? So
everyone thinks
of Prader-Willi as
an obese syndrome
and hyperphagic.
They have
development delays,
hypoclonitis, and
maybe short little
hands, small little
hands and feet.
But they don't realize
that when they were
infants, that it was
the opposite problem.
Parents had trouble
getting them to gain
weight, that they were
very, very hypotonic.
And when they get
older, you need extreme,
extreme measures to
keep their weight under
control. A lot of
times, these are the
kids, they're very
lovable, actually. Just
like Down syndrome kids,
very, very lovable.
They smile and they
look at you, but
they always want
food. So many parents,
often what you have
to do is actually
put a lock on
their refrigerator
so the kids can't
get in, lock
the cupboards in
the refrigerators
and so they don't
eat themselves to
death, unfortunately,
right? And you have
to actually tell
neighbors because
they're lovable,
they can move around.
You have to tell
the neighbors
that, you know,
Johnny might,
you know, don't give
Johnny any food.
He can hang out at
your house when he
comes, but, you
know, don't feed him.
And this is, you know,
classic overweight.
And this is in C, you
can see someone who's
controlled their
weight with the help of
an endocrinologist
and geneticist. And it
takes a lot of effort
to do this, right? A
patient I had with
part of ***** syndrome
when I was a third year
student, and I was in
an emergency room,
was unfortunately, I
think, 30 something,
40 something year old
person who came and
coded from Prada *****.
And he had basically
had a massive heart
attack at that young
age. It's because
they have all
these problems of
obesity and poor health
from the obesity.
Right.
Dermatomyositis.
I always say this one
is so easy because
it's all named dermato,
something in the skin
and myositis. So
something in the muscle,
right? So the proximal
muscle weakness um and
that means you know
the shoulders and hips
so anything that you
need those muscles they
have problems doing
right so uh brushing
the hair so the classic
uh story is that you
know he or she brush
the hair once or twice
and then they have to
kind of take a rest
trouble lifting things
or getting things
under cover uh climbing
stairs these are the
muscle the muscles that
you need, the proximal
muscles you need to
do these activities.
Classic dermatological
findings
is the heliotrope rash,
the violet colored
rash around the eyelids
and these little
joint findings, these
groton papules above
the joints, okay?
All right, Duchenne's.
Again, another
condition you're gonna
hear in other lectures.
So I'm not gonna
go over the path
physiology, but
obviously it's a
problem with the
dystrophin, right?
And the dystrophin
is not working.
So it's the mutation,
the dystrophin gene.
So, and what happens
that because it's not
working, your muscles
are obviously weak. So
this is not one of
those conditions that,
like again, Wordenhoff
and floppy or hypotonic
as an infant. These
kids, you know, they
might be a little
bit lower tone, But
usually you find that
the problem progresses
in very early childhood,
right? So something
I mentioned is that
sometimes they get
the pseudohypertrophy
of the calf. So the
calf is big, it looks
very muscular, and yet
it doesn't work right.
It's still very, very
weak. And that's because
the muscle tissue
has been replaced by
fibrous collagen and
infiltration of fat.
So it looks big. So
pseudohypertrophy is
not, it's fake, okay?
All right, again,
muscle weakness,
intellectually
impaired. So I found
these kids, they
talk, they can talk,
then they're not
severely disabled, but
a little bit
impaired, all right?
Again, pseudohypertrophy
of the calf,
waist and muscles. And
again, the cardiomyopathy
is a main problem
in morbidity and
mortality is that heart
is a muscle and the
muscle has a problem
working all over the whole
body. And so they do
get a cardiomyopathy,
usually a dilated
cardiomyopathy,
very, very common.
All right. So
early signs is, you
know, maybe just
some findings in
infancy. And as
they get older,
it becomes more
apparent, right? If you
worry about a muscle
problem or weakness
problem, Many times
we're going to order a
serum creatinine kinase
because we're going
to look for muscular
dystrophy, right?
And this is, you
know, luckily in this
case, you don't have
to do genetic testing,
order fancy chromosomes.
Creatinine kinase
is a very readily
available lab and
it can give you
answers pretty
quickly, which is good.
And death is usually
from respiratory failure.
Again, the breathing
mechanism, they can't
swallow, they choke,
they get aspiration
pneumonia. Anytime
you have weak muscles,
nothing works right.
Your mouth, the chewing,
swallowing
becomes a problem.
Heart failure,
again, that
cardiomyopathy,
heart failure,
arrhythmias they can
have. And so these
are the things that
lead them to have
more problems. They
end up wheelchair
-bound. Once you're
in the wheelchair,
you get scoliosis,
you get respiratory
compromise, you
don't breathe right.
And so that's always
a bad thing. So
you try to keep
them out of the
wheelchair with
physical therapy as much
as possible for as
long as possible,
right? And these
days, whereas early in
my career, it wasn't
uncommon to say
they'll be lucky to
leave into their late
teens or early 20s.
And now it's, I think
it's commonplace
for depending on the
severity and the
type of care they're
getting into the 30s
and 40s, okay? But it's
definitely still a
shortened lifespan,
unfortunately.
There's the classic Gower
side where a young child,
classically two years
of age, where you
could put them on
the floor and see.
And they'll tell
you, they're
not the strongest
kid in the world,
can't really
fight you off.
Or when they're playing,
not very physical.
And to get up off
the floor, whereas
kids can usually
just, pop up. These
kids, they have
to kind of use a
certain maneuver
where they kind of
brace themselves
against the knee,
right? And then they
walk themselves up
using the hands up
their thighs till they
can get straight, okay?
And that's obviously
what we call not
normal and this Gower
sign. And this picture
of a kid with this
pseudohypertrophy. You
can see poor musculature
throughout every
place, but the calves.
I personally don't
know why the calves
get pseudohypertrophy
versus other muscles,
but it's just something
we've observed.
Becker musculotrophy
is good to hear
about it. And
basically, it's still
a musculotrophy.
It's just in a milder
form, okay? So
there is some
functioning dystrophin,
which is helpful.
So
it's the same
problems, but maybe a
little bit delayed
and less severe. So
they might end up in
wheelchairs a little
later on in life
than in Duchenne's.
All right, so
let's move on from
hypotonia and let's
talk about head shapes,
right? So every
time the baby comes
in, we're always
feeling the head,
right? You see
pediatricians constantly
feeling a baby's
head, right? So that's
one of the physical
exam things that
we always check out.
And what we're doing
is we're trying
to check out the
sutures, make sure the
sutures are normal,
right?
And then we're checking
these fontanels,
okay? So an anterior
fontanel is the much
bigger fontanel. And
because it's bigger,
It also takes longer
to close. So it closes
at six months or half
a year to 18 months,
right? So half a year
to a year and a half.
That's why I always
tell students, try to
remember that because
you're going to be
asked that all the time.
And you kind of have
to intrinsically know
that because you're
going to see infants
at different times. And
you want to feel at
the two-year-old, if
it's still open, that's
not normal, right? A
four-month-old and you
don't feel an entire
final, that's not
normal. So you want to
get a sense. Usually a
good rule of thumb is
you cut it in the
middle, one year of age,
12 months is when this
is starting to close.
You see very commonly
when they come in
for the 12-month visit
and they need to get
their vaccines and lab
work, very commonly
the anterior fatenelle
is close to closing.
Posterior fatenelle,
much smaller,
actually feels much
like a little pinpoint.
And a lot of times
students have
trouble finding
it. So usually I
say, go to the
anterior fat now,
follow that sagittal
suture, and then you
see a small, slight
depression, that's
the posterior fat now.
Very small, and it
closes very, very
early, right? So around
a month and a half
to two months, it's
closed already. So when
they're getting that
first shot at two
months of age, it's
probably not even there
anymore. So if you
didn't see the baby
when the baby was first
born or, you know,
one week visit or a
one month visit, you're
probably not going
to feel the pulse
here if I don't know,
right?
Always, again, pay close
attention to the sutures,
right? And molding is
something you should
understand is that
when the baby comes out
vaginally, the baby,
you know, had to try to
fit that big head through
mom's vaginal canal.
and the head, luckily,
nature knows how to
get things done and
these sutures can move
and the head can change
shape to help the
baby's passage out into
the real world, right?
And sometimes they
have these like long,
elongated heads and we
always tell parents,
don't worry, it's
gonna pop back into
shape and the baby's
gonna have a beautiful,
round, normal
looking head, okay?
All right, so you're
always paying attention
to head shape and
the size. So the
head shape is the
head shape. We'll talk
about different head
shapes, but the size
is very important. So
one of the measurements
we're always doing
in infants up to
two years of age is
always checking the
head, right? Because
that's a sign that the
brain is growing well
too, right? Because
the reason the head
keeps on growing,
the head size keeps
on growing, is because
the brain is growing
and it's pushing
on the skull. And
that's very, very good.
so you always make
taking measurements and
sometimes the head
size is too small and
when it's too small could
be normal but sometimes
it could be a genetic
problem or brain
growth maybe the brain
got insulted lack
of oxygen or something
it could be you know
an infection process
you know what we call
torch infections you'll
hear i have a slide
later on different
torch infections as well
so these are things
you think about if
you're measuring them
and you can see that
they're like really small
heads or they're what
we call falling off
and this would be you
know a very poor sign
of poor brain growth
and or head
circumference that head
circumference is so small
in this case i'm showing
you these these ones
it's it's baby's head
is big right so and
you know big heads are
Same thing. There
could be problems or it
could be normal. So
sometimes it could be
excess cerebral spinal
fluid and it's called
hydrocephalus. And this
does happen sometimes
and something you
have to be aware of.
But many times,
especially when the
infant is a normal baby,
everything is
going great,
physical exam is normal,
sometimes you just
have to measure the
parent's head
because they all have
big noggins. Mom
and dad both have
big noggins. So what's
going to happen?
The baby has a big
nodding. So it's
called benign
familial macrocephaly.
Nothing to worry about
at the same time,
right? If you are worried,
luckily, you know,
up to until the anterior
fontanel closes,
a lot of times you
could do a head
ultrasound. So the
ultrasound machine can go
right into the fontanel
and actually get
a great picture of
what's going on in
the brain. So it's
a great window into
the brain when it's
still open, right? And
now let's talk about
some abnormal head
shapes. So we talked
about the size and
we talked about the
different shapes.
So sometimes when
they come out,
this looks like
molding, but when you
actually examine the
child, you see it's
more like a boggy
swelling. So it's not
really the molding, like
the head's misshapen.
In this case, you'd
feel a swelling
in the head. And the
swelling, you can
see, is all over the
top of the head and
it's diffuse and it's
crossing over the
different sutures.
When you feel different
sutures in the brain,
you feel, oh, it
goes past this suture.
When that happens,
you're dealing with
a Kappa, right?
Kappa-succinating.
So, but on the
other hand,
sometimes you see
a little bump,
right? Almost like a
goose egg, you know,
you ever get, you
bang your head really
hard when you're a
kid, you get this big
goose egg on your head
or on your forehead.
and I remember one
time I was playing
hide-and-seek and I
grew up in Manhattan
and playing hide-and
-seek and I was running
and I ran right into
one of those old
into a pole,
those meters and I
had this gigantic
goose egg and
my mom was like,
what happened?
Nothing.
And so what was this?
This happened is it's
blood accumulation under
the periosteum And
this happens very
commonly when the baby's
coming out, they're
having difficulty, and
the OB doctor would use
a vacuum to suction
out, put the vacuum on
the baby's head, like
this is the vacuum, and
put it on the baby's
head to help the baby
come out through the
vaginal canal. Now,
sometimes obviously it can
cause some minor trauma
and some accumulation
of blood in there.
And it's
subperiosteal. And so
it'll stop at the
suture line. All
right, so it won't
cross the sutures
because it happened
right there.
All right, and so
it doesn't cross
over to the other
side. Like to say,
this is a sagittal
suture, it won't
cross over, all
right? And so nothing
really to do, just
reassure them.
It looks uncomfortable.
And sometimes
you do have to
tell the parents So
when all the blood
goes away and gets
reabsorbed, that there
might be a little
hardness or
calcification. Again,
that will go away
over time as well.
Don't know exactly
when, but the body has
a way of going back
to homeostasis. And
that's why a lot
of times our job as
pediatricians is very
easy because usually you
just do nothing and
reassure them and
things get better.
You just have to know
when is a problem
and when most times,
luckily, it's mostly
reassurance, all right?
You do have to
worry a little bit
because you're
going to be doing
the heme and
lymph system in a
little bit, maybe
in a few months.
Blood accumulation in
infants, not great,
right? Because that's
going to cause a
bilirubin load when
that blood is being
resorbed. And so the one
thing that you do have
to worry about with
cephalohematoma is
that baby is jaundice,
that yellow color
they get with the
buildup, the bilirubin,
you know, this is a
little bit increased
risk factor because
this is going to kind of
feed into that system
a little bit more.
And you have to
be a little more
watchful if you
have a baby with
a cephalohematoma
and jaundice.
Just something, a preview
for your future learning.
And here is a cap. And
that's how I remember
it i teach your students
this cap goes on
your whole head not
just on one side and so
that's what a cap
would be like all right
again more different head
shapes it's important
to know because parents
will ask you right
parents want to know
like is my child going
to look like this
forever have this weird
looking head shape um
and it's important for
us to know what what
to counsel them on so
these ********* babies
you know what we call
when they came out
too early it's very
common for them to
have this long anterior
posterior like that movie
Aliens and long head.
Luckily most times
when they grow
up things kind
of even out again
they have hair you
don't notice it
as much but it's
very very common.
That brachycephaly is
a very short bulbous
head right like
Megamind so that cartoon
character is a bulbous
head and sometimes it's
you know it's you have
a ********* fusion of
the coronal suture if
it's not severe a lot
of times no one does
anything about it but
sometimes you'll see
it and and what happens
that if this is fused
prematurely the brain
can't grow this way
anymore so it's going to
grow in every other
direction right the brain
is constantly going
to put pressure where
it can right and if
if there's a physical
constraint it's just
going to go other places
so the brachycephaly
but the most common head
shape we see all the
time is what we call
positional plagiocephaly
the baby's head is
kind of flat on one
side or both sides but a
lot of times it's flat
on one side and you
kind of get this like
kind of parallelogram
head a little bit all
right um and it's really
because these days the
baby is on the back
most of the time right
so we have a back to
sleep campaign where
the safest position to
prevent SIDS, sudden
infant death syndrome,
is for babies to sleep
on the back. And we
tell parents that babies
are eating or sleeping
most of the time. So
they're on the back
a lot and it starts
getting a little flat.
And we tell them,
you still have to put
the kid on the back
to sleep. Don't worry
about it. But when
the baby is awake, you
can put the baby on
the belly, more belly
time for them to play,
keep some pressure
off the head. And it's
only for the first
few months, because
once they're like four
to six months of
age, they start, you
know, being more upright,
and then they don't
have that pressure
on the head anymore.
Sometimes it can be
worsening. If the kid
have torticollis, you
know, sometimes we
have torticollis,
you wake up with that
right neck and your
head's kind of stuck
in one place. Well,
babies can be born like
that, where they
have this tight
sternocleidomastoid muscle.
And what you want to
do is try to stretch
that muscle, right?
Stretch that muscle
and sometimes you do
physical therapy
and tell the parents
certain conditions to
kind of stretch that
muscle. But you can
imagine if one side
is constricted, the
baby's always going
to be kind of on one
side of the head,
one side of the head,
and that's going
to be flattened a
lot more. Again, most
of the time, nothing
severe Unless, and
the baby's head will
pop back into shape
And the biggest thing
is what they look
like in their face,
right? So your back of
the head can look all
funky and asymmetric
No problem, especially
when you grow up You
have hair, everything
kind of evens out
But you never want your
face to be asymmetric,
right? No one wants
a quasi-modal face
and that's what a lot
of this is is important
to understand in in
kids on when when
you have to refer or do
when can you reassure
and when do you have
to refer all right
and i wrote something
about a helmet and
you see a picture of
a helmet you can put
molded helmets and
the helmets are molded
in a certain way that
it could put pressure
on certain parts of
the of the head to kind
of pop it back into
place all right so
in this case it would
probably put pressure
on this side to keep
this from growing, so
kind of start expanding
this part, okay?
All right, so the biggest
problem we worry
about if we see
asymmetric heads is
their craniosynostosis,
right? So basically, are
the cranial sutures,
which you saw,
you know about already,
are they abnormally
fused? So they should
fuse in a certain
way at a certain time.
So if they fuse too
early, that's a
problem, or abnormally.
And so what I always
say, usually when
you're feeling the
head and sutures,
it should feel
like a flat plane.
It should be flat.
You can maybe feel
the opening, but
it should be flat.
You should not feel
mountain ranges.
the Appalachian
Mountains in the
sutures. That means
the two plates are
sliding together,
forming that
mountain range,
and that is not normal.
And the biggest
thing you're looking
for is asymmetry
of the face,
forehead, eyes,
ears,
right? Abnormal.
Nose creases should
be equal, right? And
if you do see asymmetry
to the face and or
you feel these sutures
that make that is
making head misshapen,
you want to get a
3D CAT scan or neurological
consult, right?
Because they might
need surgery to
correct it. So in this
case, the left coronal
suture is a problem.
And even though it
doesn't show here,
you probably feel that
little ridging or
mountain, that little
mountain range. And
because this suture is
a problem, this side
won't grow properly.
So everything else
is growing. So you
have what we call
bossing of the forehead.
It's kind of bulging
out. It's causing
the eyes, putting
pressure in the eye
socket to be misshapen.
Sometimes you can
see the ears being
downward displaced,
the nose crease
abnormal compared
to the other side.
So you can see
it's more of a
It's usually just a
cosmetic issue, but
it's significant.
So in this case,
this infant
will definitely
go to surgery.
These are 3D CAT
scans. You ever see 3D
CAT scans that we order
for cranial sinusitis?
It's amazing the
detail. You can see
all the sutures and
everything. So in this
case, this is the
issue that's a problem.
all right so a picture
of a helmet uh kids
are so cute when they
wear these helmets and
luckily most of the
time with positional
plagiocephaly you don't
have to do anything
right so um i had a
colleague that asked me
showed me pictures of
all the cat scans gave
me the full rundown and
the neurosurgeon said
yes no and should we
get a helmet and i
really you know based
on my experience i was
like no i if you're
telling me everything's
good head's growing
normally a little
asymmetric, a little flat,
the front of the face.
She sent me pictures
of her baby, perfect.
I was like, I don't
think you need a
helmet. You can
just watch. And a
couple years later,
everything's fine.
So luckily, like I
said, in pediatrics,
luckily, most of
the things are
good, right? And
this is a picture of
some surgical procedures
they can do. It's
really like carpentry
where they cut,
they literally cut
pieces of bone to give
spaces for things to
grow and basically
cut out the place,
the things that were
fused abnormally,
which is in this case,
the sagittal suture,
okay? Here, the
coronal suture is a
problem. So what do they
do? You have to cut
that piece so that
the brain can grow
symmetrically, right?
There's a couple of
Syndromes, there's
more than a couple,
but these are the
two most popular
syndromes. If you're
going to be a pediatrician
to hear about,
I just want you guys
to hear about it.
And there's cruzone
and apron, okay?
So cruzone is a syndrome
associated with
craniosynostosis.
And you can see
this little girl had
the problem and
surgical correction.
Everything's good.
Cosmetically, great. It's
very, very cute, okay?
And apron, a little
bit more of a
problem because
you're not dealing
with just the
craniosynostosis. a
lot of times they
have limb defects.
So APERT has limb
defects associated
with it. And
of course, you
have some syndactyly
where you can
see these toes
are not separated.
Okay,
can't really tell from
the picture. I think
the hands are okay,
but it's hard to say.
Now here it looks
like the hands are not
okay, but maybe they
surgically fixed it.
All right, let's move on
to infectious problems
that have neurological
consequences.
So again, in
infancy, if the baby
was affected with
something in utero,
it can definitely
affect the whole body,
including the brain.
So the biggest
thing is what we call
torch infections.
This is what
it stands for,
toxoplasmosis.
O for other,
parpovirus,
varicella,
tuberculosis, fibrosis,
rubella, CMV,
******, HIV, hepatitis,
and as I always
say torches, because
you always have to
think of ******** with
congenital ********
as well. And you can,
or, you know, if you
suspect it, small
brain, maybe they have
patospenomegaly, they
have hearing loss,
abnormal rash, right?
Where you're thinking
that it could be a torch
infection, you can,
you can send titers,
we call torch titers
to see which one it
is, right? We'll talk
about meningitis a
little bit, Bell's palsy,
and just a little
throw in. I
know in my
previous lecture, I
talked about
febrile seizures,
but I didn't talk
about, there's
a couple of
conditions that are
really strongly
associated with febrile
seizures, and
that's roseola.
Roseola, one day
you learn about,
is a viral exanthemum
where you get very,
very high fevers.
And when the fever
breaks, you develop
like a non-specific
rash, and it's very
benign, nothing to
worry about. It's great
when the rash comes
out as a pediatrician,
I'm like, oh,
it's just roseola
and nothing to worry
about. But the problem
is with those high
fevers and the rapid
rise of fevers, it
can sometimes trigger
a febrile seizure.
And here in this case,
Shigella cause
****** diarrhea,
GI issues.
Shigella excretes
Shigatoxin. It's a neurotoxin
and that decreases
your seizure threshold.
And when you
decrease your seizure
threshold So plus a lot
of times you have fever,
you can get a febrile
seizure from that,
all right? So
meningitis, the biggest
thing, you're going
to learn a lot about
meningitis and you
can, it's a busy
slide, you can read
over, everything
makes sense on the
symptoms they're
having. But the biggest
thing is, luckily
in infants, we have
those fontanels.
Fontanels are almost
like an entrance hole
into the brain, which
you can look through
with a sonogram, but
you could also feel,
right? It should be flat
and soft, all right?
A lot of students
are very worried,
like, if I press too
hard, I'm going to
puncture into the
brain. No, you're
not going to puncture.
It's puff dura.
You're not going
to do anything.
But if there's
meningitis and there's
intracranial
pressure, it's
actually going to
bulge out. It's almost
like a window that
you just feel.
And it's, you know,
classically, you document
as anterior fontanelle
open and flat,
if it's flat. Or if
you suspect meningitis,
bulging fontanelle,
which is not
normal. And of
course, they can have
neurological signs,
apnea, hyperventilation.
They're not going
to act normal.
Classic thing for rounds,
especially when
you're in the ICU,
is Cushing's Triad
for increased
intracranial
pressure, irregular
respirations,
hypertension, bradycardia.
Meningitis in
infants, right?
It can be very subtle,
but that's why we
have fever if either
the temperature is very
high or if the
temperature is very low.
It's worrisome in kids.
Again, they're cranky,
they're lethargic,
they're not responsive.
Parents are very in
tune with how the
kids are just cranky,
crying all the time.
And of course, vomiting,
usually from
the increased
intracranial pressure,
apnea not breathing
right, and of course,
they can have seizures.
So you can imagine
when we talk about
febrile seizures,
you have an infant,
say you had an infant
seizing and a fever,
you know you can see why
sometimes they worry
about meningitis something
we can do something
about but giving
antibiotics and so that's
why sometimes you will
see infants getting
lumbar punctures to
rule out meningitis
right but again remember
that febrile seizures
ages six months to five
years so we're not
you know hopefully by
six months but you have
more to go with it's
an older baby versus
a two-month-old if the
two-month-old is having
seizures and a fever
you're not going to
say it's a simple
febrile seizure.
You're going to
work this infant
out, especially
you're going to
rule out meningitis,
right?
You're going to learn
about this in DPR,
Koenig's sign
and Brzezinski's
sign. But the
biggest thing,
takeaway in this
pediatric lecture,
is that this test
is not reliable
in infants or young
children, right?
They may not have
this sign, so
don't rely on
it. You can still
do it, but it's
not reliable.
All right, let's
move on to infant
botulism. I know you
got a little bit of this
in a previous
lecture. The biggest
takeaway is that honey,
okay? You don't give
honey to kids under
one year of age.
It can cause, those
spores can cause
problems in kids, okay?
So most honey jars
have that disclaimer,
but the problem is
parents don't read
the honey jars. And
definitely grandmas,
who's the biggest,
you know,
they're so loving,
they want to give
kids, infants, all
the good stuff.
And everyone knows
honey is healthy
for you And things
like that But
not for young
children So it's
one of those things
we tell parents
All the time
Findings that you can
have That's progressive
hypotonia So it's
not a kid, infant
who's born hypotonic
They're fine, they're
doing great Six
months, meeting all
the monsters All of
a sudden, they're not
acting right Now
they're feeling weak,
lethargic Again, if
you're weak, you're
having feeding problems
They start choking,
drooling, because they
have a poor gag reflex.
The neurological system
is being assaulted
by this toxin, okay?
And they can actually
go into restoration, so
it can be a significant
problem. Luckily,
we don't see it that
much anymore because
we're just more in tune
with what's going on,
and we have better
care, and we have these
labels and everything
like that. So infantile
botulism But it's
always on our radar If
you see a young infant
That's not doing well
Again, that's part
of the history Ask
them about honey Or
improperly canned
goods as well So some
people can their own
stuff And that could
be Where they're
getting the botulism
Bell's palsy
Very, very common
issue And the
biggest thing
It can be from
all sorts of
viruses. Most of the
time, we don't
even work it up.
We see Bell's palsy all
the time, and
I never send,
unless I suspect
a certain virus,
I never send studies in
general most of the time.
And the biggest
thing you have
to understand is
that the Bell's
palsy will
resolve over time
as the body just
recovers. Again, the
body's going to seek
homeostasis, and it
takes a few weeks,
But during that few
weeks, you can't close
your eye very well,
right? And so the
eye can, if you can't
close your eye, your
eye can dry out,
and that can cause
a long-term problem.
So the biggest
thing in kids, so
whenever I see kids
with Bell's palsy,
that's what I'm
focused on is that, you
know, can he or she
close their eyes?
They can't, so they
have to wear eye patch,
or they have to use
eye drops every few
hours, okay? I know
in the adult world,
sometimes they'll give
them prednisone, but
in peas we always
you know less is more
most of the time
prednisone is is a good
strong drug and it's
needed in certain cases
but in this case most
of the time you don't
need it but it's
good to know we can
give something all
right uh and you can see
in this case which
is the side that's
affected this is side
that looks uh looks fine
right so it could be
and this side is the
expressive side.
That's the normal side.
Important to know when
we're talking about
asymmetry. Sometimes
you see this in infants
and this baby doesn't
have infant neonatal
Bell's palsy. Baby,
everything's good. You
can see the symmetry
is good in the face.
There's nothing wrong
with that. It's just
the mouth is a little
crooked. So I just throw
this in because you
see it every once in
a while and it's basically
a muscular problem
around the mouth. And
there's an absence
of one of the the
muscles on one side and
over time the body will
would equilibrate and
they will have a
symmetric spine over time
all right these minor
associated with cardiac
anomalies it's good
to know so if i hear
a murmur pay a little
close attention but it's
not something i do
automatic consult or
anything all right let's
talk about trauma and
injury uh we we did a
few things we We did
the cephalemus home.
We did the cat putter
ready. And let's talk
about the, you know,
the brachial plexus.
You see this picture in
your dreams. I know
you had a whole lecture
on it. So I'm not
going to go over stuff
you already know or
already memorized. The
biggest thing in
patients, in infants, when
you pick this up, is
obviously this is the
history of a birth
trauma, a difficult birth.
and classic is this
waiter's tip pan that
you know about
right this is this
description of what's
actually going on uh
but actually in in
real life the what you
find is that you know
they don't always
have this waiter's
tip thing and you know
um i i had a baby
maybe four or five
years ago now so at
the hospital first time
everything seemed
normal it wasn't
really much of a
description of a difficult
birth history. The
baby wasn't too big.
But what I picked up was
this asymmetric
Moro reflex.
So we always do
a Moro reflex.
I think you're going
to get it in your DPR
lecture on neonatal
reflex where you pull on
their hands. Remember,
babies are flexed.
Here's the doll.
The babies have a flexed
position. You pull
on them and you just
kind of let go and
simulate dropping them.
And when you do that,
their hands splay out,
right, equal. So you
pull them up and then
you let go and their
hands splay out equally.
So in this case,
there's what we call
asymmetrical marrow.
You pull them up and
only like one side splays
out. The other side
kind of stays still.
And that's obviously
not normal.
And one thing you
have to think about is
could be a brachial
plexus injury, okay?
The other thing you
have to think about
is could be a broken
clavicle, right? So
go like this and this
side doesn't splay
out the way it's
supposed to. Think of
the clavicle or a
brachial plexus injury.
Right, Klumpke's palsy,
obviously a
worse prognosis.
Again, you learned
all about this. And
the biggest thing is
that if you suspect
brachial plexus
palsy, you always
want to put your finger
in their hand and
see if they have a
good grip, right?
Because if they have
a grip, then you're
most likely dealing
with the herbs and not
the Klumpke's. And
that's good because
herbs a lot of times
will resolve with some
physical therapy and
clump keys sometimes
doesn't. And, you
know, I remember when I
was a resident in the
OB, we were called
to a difficult delivery.
So we were ready.
And while we're
waiting for the baby to
be delivered, the
OB doctor was like
calling and hugging
on the head to get the
baby out because baby
was kind of stuck
for a long time. And
the OB definitely just
really yanked on
the baby to get the
baby out, right? To
save the baby's life.
We got the baby,
recessed the baby. And
I remember the first
thing, the OB doctor,
once everything
was stabilized over
there, came over and
he put his hand, he
put his finger into
the baby's hand and
felt the grip, right?
And he was like,
right? Because there
might still be, I
mean, he was probably
still worried. He was
worried about a brachial
plexus injury, but
he was really worried
that this could be
a clump case palsy,
which is like,
unfortunately, a lot of
times automatic lawsuit.
So, you know, the
fact that he felt the
grip in the hand, he's
like, oof, probably
not that, right,
which is good. And
the baby turned out
fine, which is great.
And sometimes it's
associated with a
Horner's syndrome as
well. Okay, you can
see a baby with a
Horner's syndrome.
All right,
a couple of words on
shaken baby syndrome.
We obviously know
it's a very, very
severe problem. And
really it's because
The baby's head is
so much bigger than
the body And they
have no muscles To
kind of fight off
the forces So if our
friend shook us You
know we're strong We're
not going to go
boom back and forth
But a baby will So
even like a parent who
has kind of lost
their sense For
temporarily Because
the baby's crying a lot
They're just stressed
They're sleep
deprived And they
shake the baby
They can cause a lot
of damage You could
read slowly in this
slide about what's
going on, but
basically you can shear
those blood vessels
and cause a subdural
hematoma and the
eye vessels as well,
and you can cause
retinal hemorrhages. So
if you suspect the
shaking baby syndrome
because the baby's
not acting right,
lethargic, vomiting,
all those signs
that there's a
neurological problem
or even seizing,
a lot of times we'll
get an optoconsult
And the ophthalmologist
would dilate the
eyes, look in, and you
could see the retinal
hemorrhages. It's
very, very unfortunate.
Obviously, it's a
child ***** case, and
authorities get involved.
And I once had a
dad, and he seemed
to be a good guy. And
one day, he just lost
it, shook his baby.
And, you know, baby,
luckily, had some
minor damage, but
recovered pretty well,
which doesn't
happen all the time.
Sometimes these babies
are really devastated
neurologically. And
he went to jail.
So as part of the
ancestry guidance,
we talk to parents
about don't shake
your baby. Just
put the baby down.
If you're upset,
you're sleep deprived.
Don't worry, the
baby's crying.
Baby's not going to cry
himself or
herself to death.
So we tell them,
especially when you see,
you're always
watching the
parent-child interaction.
Infants have
temperaments too.
Some infants are very,
very intense. Some
are very chill, right?
So those intense kids,
infants, colicky,
those are the ones,
you know, you want
to talk, definitely
want to talk a little
bit more about
never shaking your
baby. And you have
the classic crescent
-looking blood in the
CAT scan, and these
are retinal, which
is, you know, right?
A couple of minutes
on concussions.
You know, concussions,
we all have
experienced it, you
know, watching sports.
Athletes get concussions
all the time.
Basically, it can cause
a lot of symptoms.
Your brain got
insulted, right?
It can be immediate,
right? You know, you're
just watching football
and just bang, and you
can see the athlete
is dazed, you know,
walking over to the
sidelines. You can
see immediately, like,
that person probably
got a concussion, right?
But it could also
just be, you know, got
dinged, you felt
something, And then over
minutes, hours, days, it
keeps on getting worse
and worse. So concussion
is very, it's a
very gray zone. And
that's what makes it so,
so difficult, right?
The biggest thing is
that being able to
recognize the symptoms,
all right? And some
of these symptoms
here, you can see
cognitively feeling foggy,
concentrating,
difficulty remembering.
Probably how you
guys feel with all
these lectures and
studying all the time.
Emotionally labile,
irritable, sad,
more emotional,
nervous. Again,
medical student.
All right, physically,
headaches, nausea,
vomiting, balance
problems, numbing.
So you can read this
for yourself. All
right, and one thing
that people always
forget to ask is
always ask about
sleep. Sleep is
very, very important,
right? Are they having
trouble sleeping?
They have insomnia or
they're sleeping so
much, they're just
sleeping all the time,
which sometimes parents
say. or just drowsiness.
They just don't feel
right, okay? The
big treatment is
basically physical rest.
So not too many activities
at all, especially
in the beginning.
Just sleep and rest
in a dark room as much
as you want, okay?
Cognitive rest.
So no constant
texting, watching
YouTube videos,
playing video games,
none of that. You
see most of these
people that have
concussions, you'd be
seeing them wearing
sunglasses, right?
Because the light bothers
them. Loud music,
loud noise can bother
them too. Your brain
is like shaken up.
It doesn't want too
much issues, okay?
And you really
want to get
quality sleep.
Back in the day, we
said, you know,
no activities,
stay in a dark
room for as long as
you can till all the
symptoms resolve.
Now we realize
that's not normal.
The body wants to
kind of get back to
normal as when it can.
So once they start
feeling a little
better, They can do low
-intensity stuff, okay?
Maybe go for, like, a
short walk, again,
with some protection.
They can play the piano
if they, you know,
that's something the
kid likes to do. They
can start writing,
maybe watch a little
bit TV here and
there until they feel
tired. And you'll see,
they self-regulate.
They'll watch for,
like, five minutes and
they're like, all
right, that's enough. I
just want to go back
to sleep. And they
slowly build up, all
right? And recovery time
varies. The biggest
thing is that parents,
a lot of times,
coaches, the student
feels pressure to kind
of go back into sports,
right? How do they
get the concussion?
Football, soccer,
lacrosse, whatever.
A lot of times that's
what it is. And
they want to return
and get back to
normal. The team's
counting on them, things
like that, right?
And what you really
have to do as a
pediatrician is like,
hey, hold on. We don't
want to cause more
damage until your
brain is fully healed.
So you really have
to do a good neuro
exam And then to be
100% asymptomatic
So I had a kid
who was putting a
lot of pressure
On me to clear him
for sports He got
up playing soccer
He wanted to get back
on the field It's been
a month He was telling
me all the right
things And again, I
can't tell whether he's
lying or not Everything
seems to be okay I
talked to mom, mom says
everything was okay
He was a teenager
I couldn't you know you
again you can't tell
where they're lying to
you did a neuro exam
and I expect a neuro
exam to be completely
normal and it was
except my last thing I'm
doing I always do my
cerebellar tests at the
end of my neuro exam
and the last thing I
said okay go walk walk
in a straight line
tandem gate and with
one foot in front of the
other right just like
you know when you're
when a cop is pulling
you over and they
suspect you drinking
and driving right and he
did everything great a
hundred percent normal
normal exam for some
reason he couldn't do
the tandem gait he was
like wobbling all over
the place and i'm like
really are you are
you joking with me
you really can't he's
like no i'm trying i'm
trying and he really
wants to walk properly
he couldn't right so he
just shows you that's
luckily we did that
unfortunately i had to
keep him out of sports
for like another month
uh maybe even six
weeks until he came
back he was able to do
everything, everything
was resolved, and then
cleared him back to
sports, okay, it's more
for the safety of his,
him and his brain's
long-term future, at
that time, teenagers
think that's the most
important thing in life,
is getting back into
the soccer field, but,
you know, we know we
can have more long
-term thinking, that's,
you know, long scheme,
long-term scheme of
things, that's super
important, okay, here's
a couple summary slides,
which I like to try
to do for you guys,
and I think the
more important
points I want
you guys to know
lecture feedback
form and por favor
and then here thank
you for another
session and look
forward to one more
with you guys
maybe a couple more
bye bye